hoy es 1 Gran día
creo que tenemos 1 Gran presidenta
de el congreso
que ya ha anunciado 1 Paso muy importante
la incorporación de las distintas lenguas eh
oficiales del estado eh
para poder ser utilizadas en en el eso
el reconocimiento de esa prulinacionalidad
y de esa riqueza cultural de nuestro país
y eso es lo importa
y cada situación la iremos viendo en su momento
de momento eh creo que toda España ha comprobado
que el resultado de la jornada de hoy ha sido bueno
esto VA consolidando eh
esta legislatura
y VA haciendo avanzar en la posibilidad
de obtener 1 gobierno de coalición
y sobre todo insisto
si algo ha quedado y acreditado
es que no hay alternativa al gobierno
de coalición de izquierda
con el sustento de las fuerzas democráticas
que el partido popular
y la ultraderecha de Vox no están en condiciones
de gobernar España
que son incapaces incluso de
ponerse de acuerdo entre ellos
para algo tan relativamente sencillo
como tener ambos presencia en la Mesa del
y aparte ya hemos visto
y hemos conocido
lo que ha ocurrido con la conformación
de el gobierno de Aragón
y nuevamente las primeras medidas
medidas negacionistas de los problemas reales
de este país de la sociedad eh
acabando con la consejería de igualdad
negando los problemas de las mujeres
y acabando con la consejería de cambio climático
negando los inmensos problemas de este planeta
debido al evidente cambio climático